dank einer klasse der damen und herren
wir sehen es bereitete einigen der denn
heute geht es um dritter luca pizza 2.0
nicht daran denke an hatte die identisch
sind auch meinen kanal und ich wissen
was abgeht ich liebe pizza über alles
und letztes jahr habe ich bereits eine
pizza rausgehauen dies in regis und
edeka es in deutschland gab zusammen mit
us dafür wusste und diese pins aber eine
pizza margherita haben und einige leute
meinen mag es ein bisschen langweilig
selbst wegen haben wir uns gedacht
kommen wir machen eine zeit die pizza
und diese teams haben keine wahl regiert
wird komplett anders sein es wird immer
noch eine pizza sein und ich werde euch
auch in diesem video nicht verraten was
es für eine pizza sein wird allerdings
habe ich erste infos am start für euch
und da ich so viele nachrichten bekommen
von wegen die zweite mit seinem kopf die
zweite bild zeigt sagt es ganz kurz
15 peter ist angepeilte release termin
der low carb in satzvey die zweite sache
die ich euch mitteilen möchte weil das
sehr sehr sehr sehr viele leute
bemängelt haben bei der ersten pizza
heyo k die hübschen liegt bei mir in
buxtehude nicht parieren westlb die luca
pizza 2.0 wird es im kopf haben sie
diesen rewe und edeka in deutschland
geben also jeder rewe und edeka hat die
möglichkeit die zu bestellen aber wir
können natürlich nicht wissen was der
herr prinz im vorort von stuttgart da in
sein sortiment wollt also herr fritz
männerorden luca pizza to find you weiß
fritz auf jeden fall meine damen und
herren 50 cent hat ganz ganz fett im
kalender eintragen
es wird sie in nahezu jedem regal in
deutschland geben ich würde sagen 999 99
und 9 99 prozent die frage stellt wie
sie decker tom aus der karton der ersten
luca meyer so aus komplett clean
komplett weiß was sie meinen kanal
design et cetera pp allerdings haben uns
gedacht bei dem körper 28 ich weiß ein
airbus schwarz sein also das hier ist
der karton der nun kapitza 2 1 komplett
schwarzer karton mit einem weiteres mal
die darauf wieder schlicht gehalten wir
dachten uns einfach erstens hält weiß
schwarzen wird ich bin locker wie heißt
ihr schreibt für die kommentare
für di luca pizza zwei der damen und
herren es wird ein schwarzer kartons
seiner 15 10 wird es im supermarkt geben
und zwar in jeder gottverdammten rede
erika endlich das gewitter
es sei alles gesagt was sie zu tragen
möchte weil natürlich klar ihr wollt
alle wissen wonach schmeckt die wir die
so sei die danach schmecken ist es damit
noch nach blitzer drauf ehrlich noch
nicht zu sagen
denn später ein paar wochen weil welche
sagen wir die kuh kapitza zwei sie zu
hause wird so schmeckt echt dann würden
sich bestimmt einige andere pc
hersteller denken hey die school die
bringen wir vor ihm raul deswegen weil
der damen und herren ich mache das ganze
erstmals auch zusammen gewissen secret
aber ich kenne schon mal sagen es wird
es hat das was wir machen noch nie wie
tiefkühlen egal in supermärkten in
deutschland gegeben oder weltweit
ich weiß nicht ich kenne nicht jedem
supermarkt in indien aber er wird auf
jeden fall ultra ultra kratz leute die
hinter der kamera dabei schon bescheid
dass auch jetzt war alles was ich tun
kann ist zwar erst einmal sagen wird
also leute streicht euch auf jeden fall
eine 15 zehnten ganz nett mit textmarker
an im kalender aber ich habe noch eine
zweite seite die ich euch mitteilen
möchte wenn ich schon werbung mache dann
mache ich es auch richtig luca schock
ich hab immer wieder tausende sticker
signal zum regenbogen sticker mit der
breit flagge und meine damen und herren
wenn ihr das video gerade sieht es der
19 leute das heißt ab heute bekommt hier
zu den nächsten tausend bestellungen im
luca schock immer einen signierten
sticker das wunder - so finden sich zu
jedem artikel lukas shop sondern nutze
jedem artikel war auch eine
regenbogenflagge dran ist das heißt wenn
ihr ab heute dass luca shop bestellt
wurde regenbogenflagge dran ist und ihr
seid einer der nächsten 1000 bestellen
dann bekommt ihr auf jeden fall in
signierten sticker allerdings ist das
noch nicht alles sondern ich habe auch
noch drei scherzen sie ziehen ihr
treiber hier ein held lauf
der schrift braucht an einer ein graus
oder schweinebauch burgund einmal 19
europa weiße shirt und vettier einer der
nächsten tausende steller seitdem luca
shop ab geht die chance dieser dateien
familie signiertes t shirts dazu zu
bekommen
das heißt wenn die ganzen glück
abbestellt ihr was das auch noch gerade
reduziert ist bekommt noch kostenlosen t
shirt dazu wo ich drauf unterschrieben
habe und die bekommen sie in ihren
regenbogens ticket ist wie weihnachten
und ostern ist an der stelle wird das
heute videos allerdings auch werden
würde da haben alles tut mir leid dass
ich eigentlich nur über die luca pizza 2
und den job jetzt geredet habe
allerdings halten heute die zusage
bekommen dass wir den 15 10 schaffen
werden meine damen und herren d h
damit zählt die pizza haus kommen und
das merge ich meine ich hab seit monaten
nicht so richtig zu meinem job gesagt
und da wollte ich euch auch kurz noch
mal ein bisschen was zurückgeben und
hausen sticker 15.10.10 kalender
eintragen und las neigt aber nichts
video gefallen hat und